the fast and furious movies have often
gotten away with more than just
outrageous stunts and instances of
spectacle
from bizarre character developments to
outdated plot devices
here are questionable things on the fast
and furious movies
that we all just ignore fast and furious
6 ends with a bang by revealing that
deckard shaw played by jason statham
was the one responsible for killing han
played by sung kong in tokyo drift
with this action the character's
intimidating nature was solidified
from there shaw caused all kinds of
problems for dominic toretto and his
surrogate family
including blowing up toreto's home by
the end of furious 7
the gang's most ruthless adversary had
finally been defeated
seemingly putting an end to his
influence on the lead characters
of fast and furious except the face of
the furious decided to go in the
direction of making him an ally to the
team
as he took on a new villain cipher
played by charlize theron
by the film's end sure wasn't just a
helpful colleague he ended up being the
one to save doretto's kid from the evil
henchmen
it was strange to see someone
responsible for murdering han getting
chummy with tireto's
family including for fast and furious
sixth director justin lin
via cinema blend linchette somebody
asked me about han and deckard shaw
i was like wait what sure is at the
barbecue in eight
really i was so confused one of the big
reasons to come back to direct f9
was i felt like we needed to correct
something if even one of the main
directors of the fast and furious
franchise has puzzled by this
development
then maybe sure shouldn't be a part of
the family
though brian o'connor played by paul
walker returned from the fast and the
furious to headline too fast too furious
dominic taretto did not this meant the
square-jawed law enforcement officer
needed an experienced rebel to bounce
off
of enter roman pierce played by tyrese
gibson
who had a more friendly personality than
toreto from the start and was clearly
around to help maintain the buddy buddy
dynamic of the first movie
but while he delivers his share of
comedic lines throughout the film
pierce is not at all supposed to inhabit
the archetype of comic relief
when tokyo drift opted to focus on
entirely new characters
both o'connor and pierce were put on the
back burner in fact
pierce disappeared from the franchise
before finally returning nearly a decade
after his first appearance
in fast fife this time around though
tereto and o'connor were firmly in the
lead roles again
meaning pierce wasn't needed to fulfill
his original job as o'connor's new
partner
but since he had to fill out a new niche
pierce has taken on the role of the
franchise's comic relief
which has required the character to act
drastically different
than when he first showed up in too fast
too furious
while this new personality does make
pierce's character wildly inconsistent
between his debut appearance and his
later escapades in the franchise
it has also allowed him to stick around
as a prominent fixture of the fast and
furious
universe and for that we're thankful
when the fast and the furious tokyo
drift hit theaters in june 2006
it wasn't meant to be something
significant in the franchise it was an
attempt to try something new
and see if the series could extend
beyond brian o'connor the filmmakers
certainly weren't thinking about it
factoring into an insanely convoluted
timeline in one of the biggest action
franchises ever made
as a result the use of flip phones the
car models and even the presence of bow
wow in the film's cast
all pointed to tokyo drift being firmly
set in the year 2006.
however this would get extra complicated
as the fast and furious franchise
eventually updated to retcon tokyo drift
as happening far further in the future
in 2013
han's death in tokyo drift was
established as having taken place right
after the events of fast and furious 6.
meanwhile furious 7 followed up on
toreto's brief cameo in the third film
by having it revealed that he wanted to
talk to tokyo drift protagonist sean
boswell about han
suddenly a movie previously supposed to
take place in 2006
was now rooted in 2015. nearly a whole
decade
after it was initially released trying
to flip the timeline of the fast and
furious universe like this
was almost audacious enough to be
admirable however
it definitely made the mythos of a
series about vehicles zooming by really
fast
even more difficult to follow in fast
and furious
letty played by michelle rodriguez is
murdered which is a tragic development
for dom
and a puzzling one for the franchise
after all letty hadn't been a part of
the series since the original the fast
and the furious
and now she was suddenly dead however
the post-credits scenes of fast five
shows that letty has taken a cue from
mark twain in that the rumors of her
death are greatly exaggerated
in the next movie fast and furious 6
letty is not only confirmed to be alive
but she is also shown to be working for
the movie's principal foe
owen shaw who apparently rescued her
when she was nearly dead
oh and she's also got amnesia which
means she has no remorse about working
for sure or shooting at her boyfriend
leti's death and resurrection is a
puzzling story term for the series on a
number of levels
particularly in the awkward way the fast
and furious movies refuse to give a more
detailed explanation
for how exactly she survived the fact
that her amnesia is only sporadically
referenced in furious 7
and barely mentioned in the fate of the
furious is also strange
especially as it makes her heel turn in
fast and furious 6 feel
extra unneeded audiences come to these
movies for the unbelievable there's no
question about that
but going this route with handling the
death and revival of a franchise fixture
like letty
feels one degree too far elena nives
played by elsa pataki isn't one of the
most famous fast and furious characters
but she has one of the strangest plot
lines in the entire franchise
first introduced in fast five as aligned
with luke hobbs
played by dwayne johnson thus making her
an adversary for the principal
characters
she's eventually shown to be dating
dominic taretto at the start of fast and
furious 6.
her status as toreto's new love interest
isn't long for this world though
as letty comes roaring back into the
series with this same movie
afterwards in furious 7 elena is shown
working alongside luke hobbs once again
and there are even hints that a
relationship could be forming between
the two
their bond is reinforced by how she's
tasked with taking care of his daughter
all of those plot lines vanish in the
fate of the furious
when elena is suddenly brought back to
the forefront of the continuity
as a mother of toreto's child all her
progress as a character independent of
dom from furious 7 vanishes
and suddenly she's a mother of his
newborn baby there are a lot of
questionable aspects about this plot
detail
including how the timeline doesn't quite
add up tiretto and elena's kids should
be much older than a newborn considering
when they last were intimate
not to mention how all of this feels
totally out of character for elena
and then her quick death caps off one of
the most bafflingly executed plot lines
in a series not short on strange
narrative details
the fast and furious movies aren't
famous for their post credit scenes but
fast five features a moment worth
sticking through the credits for
here luke hobbs is informed by two fast
to furious character
monica fuentes played by eva mendes that
letty is alive and well despite dying in
fast and furious
not only did the sequence indicate that
a franchise staple was getting
resurrected
but it indicated that fuentes was due to
reappear in the fast saga
after previously only appearing in the
second film fuentes returning to this
series opened the door for mendez to
play a more active character
however fast and furious 6 failed to
follow up on this teaser for returning
and since then there have been no
further appearances by fuentes
this is likely partially due to ava
mendes taking a self-imposed sabbatical
from acting
but it's still strange that fast five
teed up a return for monica fuentes
that's yet to pay off perhaps a
prospective female-led fast and furious
spin-off
can finally give fuentes a new adventure
to embark on that's more substantive
than a post-credits sequence
prior to the release of the fate of the
furious rumors spread that the
characters of luke hobbs and decatur
were being primed for their own spin-off
movie this was set up in the fate of the
furious
which saw the duo being incarcerated
together at the same prison
in this fantastic action sequence they
engaged in a scuffle during a prison
breakout
before being forced to work together to
take down cypher
and over the course of the story hobson
sure did grow closer
to the point that they shared a laugh
together and were even depicted mingling
at dom's barbecue during the film's
closing scene
once that spin-off got off the ground in
the form of hobson shaw
suddenly the two were no longer buddies
at the start of the movie
they were recruited by their respective
governments to save the world and there
was an immediate animosity between the
duo
no way i'm not working with this guy
i've been there done that
rather than being friendly they were now
inhabiting a classic buddy cop dynamic
as they aimed a slew of jokes at one
another taking shots at qualities they
hated about one another
it was like they automatically reverted
to their dynamic from the start of the
fate of the furious without any
consideration of how the rapport had
evolved once they left the slammer
hobson sure featured many stunts that
strange credulity
but the awkward way the two leads
reverted to an exclusively antagonist
dynamic
was especially weird when the fast and
the furious
hit theaters in 2001 a big takeaway for
general moviegoers was the presence of
vin diesel
with his gravelly voice and a believable
sense of authority
diesel wasn't your average movie star so
it seemed like a no-brainer to bring him
back for the inevitable sequels
however when too fast too furious was
released diesel was nowhere to be found
even as fellow original lead paul walker
was back in the driver's seat
it was a puzzling move for the franchise
and in the sequel the absence is chalked
up to touretto being on the run from the
law
in the context of the real world though
it was due to vin diesel both having
qualms with the script for too fast too
furious
and having a desire to break away from
the franchise to do the chronicles of
riddick instead
this decision allowed diesel to follow
his own creative pursuits
but it did result in the baffling site
of seeing a fast and furious movie not
headlined by the actor most associated
with this franchise this trait has only
gotten more puzzling as the years go by
and diesel remains more and more of a
fixture of this saga
brixton lore played by idris elba is the
most advanced adversary to ever appear
in a fast and furious movie
he isn't just ruthlessly violent he's
also outfitted with cyborg enhancements
the first explicitly sci-fi character
and the fast and furious mythos
isn't someone you can take down with
these so considering the leads of hobson
sure are just normal human beings you'd
think it would take a super complicated
tactic to defeat lore
and save the world instead the duo is
able to take him down
simply by learning the valuable lesson
that punching him separately isn't
working
no they have to punch him together
it's a ridiculous blood turn meant to be
the culminating teamwork of the two
leads who can't stand each other
unpredictable to boot even for a fast
and furious movie
this tactic for bringing down the body
is pretty questionable
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one